[Musique]
attentes et excitation dans le marché by
d'ottawa tous les moyens sont bons pour
entrevoir ne serait ce qu'un tout petit
peu celui qui portera un jour la
couronne britannique
on a peu vu grand chose mais j'essaie au
loin on a vu les prix en baisse quand
même ses libertés certains y ont attendu
des heures pour deux secondes de
proximité avec la royauté
dans la foule phoenix essaient de se
faufiler sans succès afin de se
rapprocher de son idole coeur qui bat
très fort c'est un moment très important
pour moi certains ont eu plus de chance
et partage ce moment avec leurs proches
je suis content parce que certaines
personnes n'ont pas pu la fiole un tutu
roi mais
une cérémonie pour honorer les anciens
combattants canadiens une visite à la
communauté ukrainienne des élèves choyé
d'une école primaire une visite royale
alors que le sentiment envers la
monarchie semble se refroidir un
canadien sur deux croit qu'il faut
abandonner la monarchie
constitutionnelle au québec c'est
presque trois personnes sur quatre je
trouve ça vraiment un affront à la
démocratie et des enfants d'outre-mer
mes valeurs à de la monarchie à sont
démodés dont la foule le fossé des
générations est bien visible veut
prendre votre l'arrêt l endroit comme ça
pour mon petit-fils aussi je trouve que
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant mais
lui ne semble pas convaincu mais les
familles c'est pas aussi excitant pour
moi la reine elizabeth ii conservent la
côte d'amour de 63 % des canadiens à
égalité avec son petit fils william à
60% mais le pré charles reste le
mal-aimé avec 29 pour ça qu'en savait sa
chance de prendre de trop me il vaut
bien farce et c'est pour ça qu'ils
viennent nous voir comme un qui soit
connu il va devenir ce qu'on voit c'est
une tournée royale pour gagner le coeur
des canadiens une poignée de main à la
fois ici christian noël radio canada
ottawa